hallo leute willkommen zu unserer easy
german serie über die wichtigsten
deutschen werben
heute geht es um das werk müssen wir
zeigen euch wie es konjugiert und in
verschiedenen zeit form verwenden könnt
los gehts präsens ich musst du musst er
sie es muss wir müssen ihr müsst wie
müssen
janosch hat sehr viel getrunken jetzt
muss er auf die toilette
ich muss unbedingt auf die toilette
hallo leute ich muss euch jemanden
vorstellen
wir haben ein neues mitglied bei easy
germany name ist sophie hallo muss ich
wirklich im bild sein
da musst du das schaffst du ihr müsst
euch zusammen reichsten ja wir arbeiten
für easy german und es muss was werden
bitte präteritum ich musste du musstest
er sie es musste wir mussten ihr musstet
sie mussten
alina ist alles gut muss ich mir sorgen
machen
nein ich musste nur kurz mit meiner
mutter telefoniert und warum musstest du
sie anrufen
ich muss dir leider sagen dass ich hier
nicht beim umzug helfen kann
theoretisch gibt es auch eine perfekt
form von dem verb müssen die würde so
gebildet werden dass man das wieder mit
dem werk haben macht zum beispiel ich
habe gewusst dass müsst ihr euch aber
nicht merken weil es sehr unnatürlich
klingt und wir das überhaupt nicht
benutzen
konjunktiv 2 ich müsste
du müsstest er sie es müsste wir müssten
ihr müsstet sie müssten
was müsst ihr tun um besser deutsch zu
lernen
ihr müsstet mehr mit menschen sprechen
ihr müsstet selbstgespräche führen
ihr müsstet mehr texte schreiben ihr
müsstet euer hörverstehen trainieren
indem ihr jede woche unseren podcast
hört ihr müsst euch einen tandem partner
oder eine partnerin suchen
ihr müsstet euch karteikarten mit den
wichtigsten vokabeln machen
ihr müsstet mehr bücher lesen ihr
müsstet deutsche lieder hören und ihr
müsstet jede woche easy german gucken
zukunft ich werde müssen
du wirst müsse er sie es wird müssen wir
werden müssen
ihr werdet müssen sie werden müssen
ich hasse es vor der kamera zu stehen
du wirst dich daran gewöhnen müssen wohl
oder übel
wir werden heute noch länger arbeiten
müssen oder ebay
hey ich werde heute früher nach hause
gehen müssen
ihr werdet ohne mich klar kommen müssen
klar kriegen wir hin
okay weil wir man sehen muss die blende
was endlich muss um die blende ist das
nicht so keine ahnung so viel wir werden
uns richtig was einfallen lassen müssen
das war unsere super easy german episode
zum verb müssen wir hoffen es hat spaß
gemacht und ihr konntet viel davon
mitnehmen wenn ihr noch mehr
unterstützung von uns möchtet dann könnt
ihr ein mitglied von easy german werden
und transkripte interaktive übungen und
vokabel listen zu jedem video erhalten
tschüss und bis bald janka so lustig ich
habe die ganze serie in einer nacht
durch künstliche wusste so lachen
[Gelächter]
ihr müsst